americans will decide who controls
congress in november a senate seat will
be up for grabs in ohio where voters go
to the polls today in a crucial primary
election the gop candidate who won the
endorsement of former president trump is
in a close race with three other
republicans all of them say they are the
true heirs to trump's legacy today's
primary is expected to be the first
major test of former president's ongoing
influence on republican politics robert
costa is at a polling place in columbus
the state capitol robert how is this
election in ohio shaping up
good morning the polls here in columbus
ohio they have just opened but the
senate republican primary race it's
still a toss up whatever happens here
tonight will reveal a lot about where
both parties stand ahead of this
november's midterm elections
the best president of my lifetime the
great donald j trump
he's not on the ballot but republicans
running for ohio's senate seat are
betting former president trump is still
on voters minds i supported president
trump yesterday i support him today and
i'll continue to support him tomorrow
trump reshaped the crowded race by
backing best-selling author and
political outsider j.d vance most
importantly j.d you're supported by me
even though vans didn't always support
trump he's a guy that said some bad
about me
former state treasurer josh mandel is
also campaigning as the trump candidate
despite not getting his endorsement
listen the trump voters are on my side
and on sunday even the former president
himself seemed to mix up mandel and
vance we've endorsed
j.p right j.d mandel
and he's doing great
jd vance is hoping today the former
president's followers spell it right is
the trump endorsement enough to put you
over the top i think it is
the endorsement vaulted vans to the top
of the polls but he's still within the
margin of error perhaps splitting the
trump vote and providing an opening for
moderate state senator matt dolan
tuesday's showdown will kick off a seven
week stretch of primaries that will test
the power of the trump endorsement i
love donald trump here in ohio trump's
support is strong but some republicans
like retired 78-year-old tom clarkson
are more focused on rising inflation
the money doesn't go as far as it used
to
it seems like you're saying former
president trump's influence in the
republican party your party is fading
i think so
it should
we've spoken to so many voters here in
ohio what's interesting is we haven't
heard a lot of partisan anger but we've
heard so much economic pain high prices
on gas at the grocery store that's what
really seems to matter to voters here in
ohio tony
yeah that's what helped get president
trump elected in the first place we'll
see if his sway still matters there in
the great state of ohio robert thank you
very much